[Musique]
c'est évidemment en chantant que se sont
accordés ces participants de la première
édition de ces six music une journée
dédiée à l'apprentissage de la musique
pour les personnes déficientes visuelles
pour une première je trouve que c'est
une réussite parce que la quantité de
monde présent et les personnes porteuses
de handicap c'est eux qui vous diront
que et bien les choses bougent mouche en
leur faveur et je suis contente et fière
j'apprends énormément va devenir
musicien ou compositeur c'est maintenant
possible grâce à la haye mao musique
assistée par ordinateur
les participants ont pu découvrir ce
logiciel de création musicale accessible
aux non voyants grâce à son assistance
vocale pour les musiciens c'est un appât
un pas de géant
puisque ça permet de
de faire des maquettes d'enregistrer
plusieurs plusieurs instruments à la
fois et pour ceux qui veulent apprendre
la musique ça leur permet de découvrir
le logiciel qui on n'a pas besoin de
grandes connaissances en musique pour
pouvoir l'utiliser
cette action vise également à rompre l
isolement des personnes déficientes
visuelles la musique comme moyen
d'expression et de partage
ligonnet
[Musique]